hallo mein name ist so herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem weiteren video
wollten eigentlich dass ich sage will
kommen heute zu einem weiteren video
weil es eigentlich das erste video heute
ist mir wird hier einmal relativ auf
gesagt ich soll mal wieder die sachen
spielen die ich damals gespielt habe
deswegen spiele ich mal wieder akinator
und suche ganz normal wie früher ein
paar sachen wo ihr sagt dass es die nun
beim akinator gibt letzte ist als
allererste suchen wir mal dieses kissen
dort hinten weil das kommt morgen am
freitag um 17 uhr in den stabiles statt
ihr müsst unglaublich schnell sein weil
unglaublich viele leute an dem kissen
interessiert sind bisher schnell
wahrscheinlich weg sein wird mir wurde
gesagt dass das auch schon mal martina
tor gibt deswegen ist die figur
männlichen nein wurde die figur durch
youtube bekannt ja ist denn die figuren
einer beziehung ist eine figur älter als
15 auch nein sie ist kein tier meine
figur ist allerdings auch kein mensch
sie besteht nicht aus holz sie hat
eigentlich hast du schon wundervolle
augen oder ich sag mal ich weiß nicht
sie ist nicht mit wasser gefüllt sie
gehört kong crafter sie hat modelinie
ich meine lukas shop ist schon irgendwie
einer gewissen form modelinie ich sag
mal einfach nein sie hat die augen ja
sie ist nicht im playmobil abwehr alter
schwede im playmobil adventskalender man
das waren noch zeiten das kissen kommt
nicht aus einem kollegen geschäft sie
ist auch keine flasche sie es auch nicht
indischer herkunft sie hat kein
tierisches ausziehen sie gehört krohn
crafter also meint er denn jetzt
eigentlich konkret an hat sich nur
verschrieben oder es krohn crafter wäre
anders meine figur steht in meinem
zimmer sie hat keine blonden haare sie
spielt nicht klar wir sie trägt keine
frauenkleidung sie ist nicht passiert
nicht in der realität zu tun sie ist
nicht grün wand lp meine figur hat ein
gesicht sie hat weißes fell sie ist aus
plüsch sie ist kein hund sie ist aus
stoff ja sie ist kein schriftsteller
luca kissen was ihr seid echt leid und
das klappt ja es ist dass luca kissen
oder es wurde auch schon 26 mal gespielt
da gut das ist jetzt nicht so viel aber
wenn man überlegt dass ich das rein das
dass das einfach 26 leute darauf
gekommen
das kissen und maki nato gibt adresse
ist richtig ihre freunde werden übrigens
schnell seid beim bestellen von einem
kissen morgen also ab 17 uhr gibt es das
halt im luca shop dann bekommt ihr
keinen sticker das habe ich zwar vor
drei tagen oder so gesagt allerdings
haben wir zeitlich mit den stickern
hinbekommen deswegen bekommt ihr dazu
ein flyer aber das ist was neues also
ein flyer wo auf der einen seite weißer
hintergrund und schwarzer auf der
nordseite schwarzer und weißer smiley
und da unterschreibe ich dann drauf aber
davon gibt es nur 1000 bis 1500 stück
also ihr müsst weg gestellt wenn ihr
dieses kissen haben wollt sorry falls
ich so viel werbung mache aber ich will
euch einfach die infos geben weil bei
den letzten lounges war es immer so dass
alles so schnell weg war und dann kamen
leute allgemein so ich hab voll stadt
bestellt ich hab keine unterschrift mit
sticker bekommen freunde es ist echt
innerhalb ist geht auch minuten
das ist echt irre mir wurde außerdem
sehr oft gesagt dass es dieses ding also
diese maske hier von mir die ich
teilweise für virtual reality wollt ihr
das eigentlich noch mal haben dass ich
noch mal so wie der virtual reality
dings hiermit auf nehme ich meinen laden
youtuber geben tausend euros für htc
wolf aus und ich hab das ding gefällt 12
euro mehr zusammengebaut und mit edding
brennen also wenn ich noch mal wollte es
schreibt bahrain und in die kommentare
und werde ich damit vielleicht mal ein
horrorspiel spielen
jetzt hab ich gesagt dieses ding wurde
durch youtube berühmt es trägt keine
männerkleidung jetzt sie ist nicht mit
zusammen die figur ist auch kein
regisseur sie ist kein mensch sie gehört
com crafter sie gehört zur familie einer
deiner beziehungen
ich weiß nicht der name hat nichts mit
tanzen zu tun die figur ist keine
flasche auch nicht aus holz sie kommt
nicht auf argentinien ist kein hundes
kein tier ja sein spielzeug sie ist
nicht im playmobil adventskalender von
die hat nichts mit der sie hat in einer
gewissen form doch was mit der
elektrizität zu tun die spielt nicht
call of duty zombie dietrich keine
weibliche kleidung sie war noch nie im
knast sie hat
die augen sind schon schön sie ist nicht
als dumm bekannt ein roboter der per
anhalter reiste mich verarschen die
figur wurde durch mich erschaffen sie
kämpft nicht gegen zombies irrt kein
voller freude sie ist nicht weiblich sie
hat zwei augen sie hat kein tierisches
aus irrt nicht mit wasser zu tun sie hat
kein waren sie doch nicht auf zwei
beinen sie wohnt bei kompakter sie hat
augen wie stammt aus einem spiel endlich
der akinator ans yusen alter was ein
share dies nicht aus holz sie hat etwas
mit kontrast dazu tun sie sich mit
wasser gefüllt die trägt eine modische
kleidung dies von mir schaffen worden
die es nicht brauchen sie hatten nichts
mit musik zu tun sie stammt aus einem
videospiel sie wurde von mir ins leben
gerufen sie spielt keine rolle
dark souls sie tanz keine figur bei
let's dance east keine packer sie ist
nicht der mensch gekleidet sie hat keine
beine
es ist nicht vitello akinator ich glaube
der senator wird auch dieses gerät nicht
kommen weil wir haben im gerät ja
eigentlich auch noch keinen richtigen
namen gegeben deswegen sage ich jetzt
einfach mal vitello und vitello wurde
schon 185000 mal gespielt ob es mir
glaubt oder nicht aber unter den letzten
akinator videos wurden kommentare
verfasst von wss kommt ja mal sehr viele
kommentare von wegen jahres ob er alles
bei akinator einreicht und einen
kommentar oder mehrere kommentare waren
noch darauf bezogen dass mein
geschlechtsteil dort sein soll
das testen wir jetzt erstmal meine figur
ist könnt ihr sie hat kein ja gut meine
figur hat schon irgendwie eltern wie es
real sie ist männlich das wäre wenn du
durch youtube dies nicht älter als 35
die ist auch nie berühmt ich stammt aus
meiner familie sie hat dieselbe mutter
wie ich sie wurden nicht in der nähe von
stuttgart sie stammt nicht aus der reihe
weil mehrere tage in einem bunker gelegt
also so bestand etwa die figur mit einem
wald man meine figur hat auch keine
ohren
sie ist das nicht das kind einer youtube
sie hat etwas mit sex zu tun
sprechen sie spricht nicht latein sie
ist nicht wohl haarlocke vagina austin
powers was zum was ist dass ich kann
meine figur jeden tag sehen sie hat
keinen bart sich ja ja das schon mal sex
mit meiner figur sie ist nicht auf
instagram erfolgreich sie macht keine
kämpfe sie kann nicht sprechen ist oder
der figuren spiegel ja ich schlafe mit
meiner figur sie ist kein fisch sie nein
sie spielt nicht im porno getragen und
nicht denselben vorn haben sie es auch
nicht weiß wie ich kenne die figur schon
seit geburt ich habe ja ich hab mit ihr
zusammen gelebt meine figur ist immer
bei mir daumen
meine figur liebfrauen sie hat keine
zauberkräfte sie hat keine augen sie ist
nicht klein ja meine figur sein
körperteil sie trägt keine bh sie hat
nichts mit religion zu tun hat da die
figur nicht gestillte da gefüttert ich
habe meine figur schon mal nackt gesehen
sie spielt den keinen porno mit ich sehe
meine figur wenn ihr den spiegel schaue
hat dir deine figur schon mal ihre liebe
gestanden eine frühjahrs rally über
männerkleidung leitfigur sexy ja aber da
die figur noch nein msc vagina rapper
youtube ich glaube das wird heute nichts
mehr
das war nämlich echt ein bisschen
komisch als ich diesen kommentar da auf
einmal unter dem video gesehen habe und
ich dachte mir nur seehofer schreibt er
dass am mpg scannen und habt ihr jetzt
nachgeschaut und nein das ist zum glück
nicht der fall
das beruhigt mich schon mal ein bisschen
wenn euch dieser teil akinator gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertungen
freuen ihr findet ein link in der
beschreibung zum da ist es ab morgen 17
uhr möglich dieses kissen hier zu kaufen
und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten video
wieder haut rein was gut und teuer